I look like hella from Thor don't you
sometimes just want to club that Kevin
Smith well how about instead you join
that Kevin Smith Club oh my God we've
been having such a good time we have
hours of audio kids in the smodcast
podcast archives that you can stick into
your ear holes and listen to or do you
want to look at something are you one of
them dirty [ __ ] well then go to the
Smithsonian screening room where you can
watch hundreds of hours of video of my
entire career spanning from the
beginning up till now including my daily
Morning Show wake and bake man where we
just smoke weed hang out and I tell you
what I'm working on plus there's
exclusive event events we've had clerks
three screenings for our club members
we've had smodcast Castle exclusive
shows for our members back in Jersey we
do events all the time including movies
pop-ups and there's tons of merchandise
of course that that Kevin Smith club
members get exclusive access to before
anybody else there are so many ways into
that Kevin Smith Club ladies and
gentlemen you don't have to come through
the front door you can come through the
back door we like it that way sign up as
a clerk where you get access to all the
audio that we got or join as a mallrat
that gives you all the audio and all the
video as well or join is a fun ployee
ladies and gentlemen you'll get a new
t-shirt an exclusive that Kevin Smith
Club t-shirt every quarter or join as a
yoga hoser and get yourself something
cool like that Kevin Smith wake and bake
Bowl ladies and gentlemen those are
existing levels but what about the new
levels that's right for 2022 we've added
at some levels including the fashionable
mail you get everything that the clerk
them all rat the yoga hoser and the fun
employee gets but you also get once a
year an exclusive piece of Wardrobe from
a Kevin Smith film straight out the
viewsk universe from the secret stash
archives or join as a brand new ranger
danger man that gives you everything
that the clerk the mall rep the fun
employee and the yoga hoser gets as well
as what the fashionable male gets but
then you also once a year get an
exclusive prop direct from one of my
movies and if you've got Untold riches
coming out of your ass guess what holy
cow there's the golden calves level man
for that level you come to my house I
cook you dinner we record a podcast and
we shoot it for wake and bake and it
goes up on smodcast man very exclusive
once a year we do that join us at that
Kevin smithclub.com be a clerk be a mall
rep be a fun employee be a yoga or be a
fashionable male be a ranger danger or
be a golden calf ladies and gentlemen
I'll be waking and baking for you come
join me at that Kevin Smith Club
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
whoa I'm hiding my coughs can you tell
whoa you're doing great hey everybody
Welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am Mark Bernardin hey
hi we're back kids we were Comic-Con it
was a [ __ ] blessing and a gift to be
back after three years
amongst our peoples
um what a wild wonderful weekend thank
you for tuning in to the streams that we
did and uh the live shows uh including
you know the standard edition and then
the ones that we did on Friday and
Saturday thanks to Dave dismalchen for
coming by and hanging out and taking
over with Mark thanks for Ryan Leibowitz
for coming in and [ __ ]
um what a great [ __ ] con man and uh I
saw Mark a bunch through it
um
we did not see each other
on Saturday
for any of this post Marvel Madness so
that's what today's show is about we
covered a lot of con kids but we did not
get to talk about the most important
aspect of Khan and I say that as a guy
who had a [ __ ] movie there
it was like clerks who
three Watts because I was backstage at
Marvel just being a kid again at the
whole H panel my my panel was at Hall h
right after theirs so I was able to like
go backstage and let me tell you
something
I saw all the [ __ ] Marvel family the
entire Mary Marvel marching Society Mark
I saw all the famous [ __ ] people go
through and [ __ ] I saw the only [ __ ]
Kevin that matters Kevin feige man
did you say hi I didn't I'm like you
know I was there with uh like my wife
was with me my kid was with me uh
Chelsea
was there Austin Harley's boyfriend
and you know I kept like Jen was she
joined later on but I was next to Harley
the whole time so I kept saying Harley
that's that person that's that person or
she would be like like she's big James
Gunn fan she loves [ __ ] those
Scooby-Doo movies so aside from
everything else she sees him as the
Scooby-Doo so when he came in she was
like oh my book had gotten she's like go
say hi and I was like nah this dude
right now is like getting up there and
he's gonna give the world the first
[ __ ] Taste of Guardians of the Galaxy
I got my I can hit him up on text
anytime last thing he needs is one more
[ __ ] face or body coming in to be
like hey man unrelated to all of this
[ __ ] whatsoever I'm a professional Mark
I know what it's like backstage
if I was backstage at Tom Cruise is like
I want to come over and say hi I'd be
like hey hey
why don't you jump out of a rocket or
something so [ __ ] I'm in pre-game right
now
I wouldn't actually I'd be like Tom
Cruise let's take a selfie that's good
for me
um so I but I didn't bother anybody I I
didn't go over and say hi as much as I
wanted to and [ __ ] and even afterwards
they're coming off the panel with like a
[ __ ] adrenaline rush and [ __ ] but I
did see some really sweet uh moments
um including the fact that
right before the Guardians kids all went
out they showed the trailer I think
and they were like as a family unit
backstage
and it wasn't like a show it wasn't for
the benefit of anybody backstage
backstage is there's very few there's a
place to take pictures but there's no
cameras or anything so it was very
authentic and they were just like arms
around each other watching this thing
and they [ __ ] cried as well it was a
really beautiful like moment where you
saw the family Dynamic at work so it was
nice being a fly on the wall for that
not to mention like the entire
uh Black Panther panel like you know you
can't hide that many people uh backstage
so when I was backstage I was seeing
everything and whatnot
um yeah man it was
it was that was the highlight of the con
for me and again I had a [ __ ]
fantastic panel after them in Hall h
with my own [ __ ] show the first five
minutes of Clerks three everything went
great but
you know I generally I go to that for
business right like I like the world
that we're in but it's pretty much like
what I do for a living and last five
years I was on the IMD boat interviewing
people and [ __ ] like that so
you know being able to be backstage and
be there for a moment of pure fandom my
fandom not like just theirs it was nice
to see everyone receiving them so well
and I'm happy for them but
I was serviced like I felt like a
[ __ ] fan and I'm in the business of
like fan service pleasing fans that's
what I [ __ ] do and I felt serviced
back backstage like sitting there
watching that
that panel that that you know it was
that was my happy place I got so
emotional so many times because I was
like I [ __ ] love this [ __ ]
uh me and the kid were just like
during the [ __ ] Guardians trailer and
the wakanda trailer
just
[ __ ] copious tears the uh Ant-Man
trailer was great but so loud
um Peter was [ __ ] thunderous so you
couldn't hear some of the dialogue
um you know what we'll get into all that
[ __ ] uh how was your rest of the con
um when I when I left you on Saturday at
4 30 you were about a learner now you
are the master no I'm the master sho'
enough
um yeah finished the podcast with Dave
dismalchin whose remains one of my
favorite people what a [ __ ] what a
great guy what a pure Soul absolutely
like he just he he nailed it he killed
it he uh he did however
um make me talk about Zack Snyder
which I was trying not to do but he was
like hey so what are you making this old
Zack Snyder business and the Bots and
the the the the the Zack Snyder cut
and I was like oh you were talking about
this he's like yeah what you what do you
think about
I walk away for five [ __ ] minutes
you get yourself in Snyder trouble
he he took over the wheel and steered
the bus right into a flame War
um
did you feel in the heat
I felt no heat we navigated about as
well as I think it's possible to
navigate that
um which ultimately not by saying
anything
um and then the rest of my the rest of
my con the rest of that night was was
just going out to a lovely dinner with a
bunch of friends
um and then hitting the ew party where I
saw the best thing that I saw all
weekend is this I saw your sweet thread
tell this story it's really awesome
really really yeah no it's it's so I'm
at this part the Entertainment Weekly
party is the last official party of the
convention and it's always the big
climactic thing it's the hardest part to
get into
hard even for me and I worked at
Entertainment Weekly for 13 years and I
started that party and it's hard it's
still you have a hard time getting in I
still have our because nobody remembers
that I'm just the old man on the hill be
like this is my party I never go uh hey
I'm not a party guy but my kid like is
always like oh can we go to the
entertainment I was like you could try
but I'm not going over there and being
[ __ ] shown the door like
you don't want to be I mean she don't
really want to be associated with Silent
Bob anyway like you know she happy she
might I'm her dad but like the Silent
Bob but also a little cringe foreign
[ __ ] she don't want to go to no [ __ ]
shindig with me ever but she was willing
to go to [ __ ] like ew if I could get
her in she's willing to Sidle up a
little [ __ ] Silent Bob but like I
don't even think I could get into that
[ __ ] man they they wait for the famous
people there so you got in thank God I
got it and you know so the thing that I
saw was just two people who met each
other and the two people are
Aldous Hodge who was there as a member
of the Black Adam cats he's playing
Hawkman
um he plays hard he's wonderful like
he's been in many things but he's
forthcoming but a wonderful actor very
good I mean I I first found him in
leverage
um you know back in the day on TNT Jay J
loves that show huge level oh it's so
much fun I was big I was a massive
leverage fan and then you know he's his
career has very steadily began to grow
and grow and grow and the last time I
saw him on the screen was an invisible
man he played a cop invisible man he was
on a city on a hill with Kevin Bacon on
Showtime like he's blowing up he's in a
constant state of blowing up
um and the reason why he was the other
thing that he had a Comic-Con was he is
playing Jon Stewart the Green Lantern
Jon Stewart in a new Green Lantern
animated movie
and and you know the other thing to know
about Alice is that he is incredibly
handsome and incredibly cool like
they're looking mad very good looking
man very good looking guy and and he's
like very like uh if we were in high
school what I would have called one of
the cool kids
and he would have been like the guy who
is the like the quarterback on the
football team and is also gonna play
Lear on the High School production of
King Lear and it's also in like the art
club like he could do no wrong in any of
those things because he's one he's one
of the give up guys when you see him
you're like I should just give up
because
[ __ ] it they got it all I got one big
one for me they got it all you're just
not fair and so he's just like in this
party just kind of hanging out and
chilling and uh and somebody turns to
him and it's like hey man we should get
a picture of you guys
and the other guy in this picture is
Phil Lamar now Phil Lamar in case you're
not familiar with Phil Lamar um it's
it's hard to run down the list of his
Bona fides but
um you might know him as Marvin from Pub
Fiction who gets shot in the face you
might know him from Mad TV you might
know him from you know any number of
like voice roles like Samurai Jack and
Avatar and yes Kevin
I I know I made a prom people keep
pointing out to me in chat that I made a
[ __ ] New Year's promise to not
interrupt your story
um but but Phil goes Phil and I go back
he was a voice on the clerk's [ __ ]
cartoon
and he's also the voice of hero for us
and Masters of the Universe
shutting up
um but he he is probably of of the many
things he's he's known for
two of them that are that are at the top
list of that upper echelon of the of
that list I thought he was the voice of
static on the static shark cartoon in
the in the mid 90s in the WB and it was
also the voice of Jon Stewart Green
Lantern in Justice League and Justice
League International two animated shows
um
and so
the person who's like we should get a
picture of YouTube and Phil is like yeah
I mean they sure I guess because Phil I
don't know if Phil understands entirely
how much he's beloved in the world and
his and the the the part of the
firmament he is within not just
Hollywood but geek Hollywood
um I don't know if he understands that
he is one of the Titans that he he walks
Among Us and
yes sir I don't want to interrupt mark
because I made a New Year's resolution
about not interrupting however I also uh
wouldn't want Phil to see this and see
me standing by like a cuck saying
nothing just watching you
do oral on them I co-sign everything uh
Mark is saying and I agree I don't think
Phil understands a how [ __ ] famous he
is and be how beloved he is
absolutely and so so Phil is like yeah I
guess I'll take the picture whatever and
Aldous turns and his face goes from like
Billy D Williams cool to
seven year old kid who got cake like he
just loses his [ __ ] mind he's like
like a smile and his eyes are wide is
like do you know what this is this is
this is my Jon Stewart this is the Jon
Stewart that I watched when I was a kid
and now I'm playing [ __ ] Jon Stewart
we gotta get a picture and and then it
becomes like Aldis is like draping
himself on Phil and Phil because Phil is
a like card carrying Naruto has a Green
Lantern ring with him it's an Albus is
trying to lose their Neutron again I'm
gonna travel right and I would shred
away and by Greek by you know by Darkest
Day in black as night like they're doing
the oath like it's the most adorable
thing I've ever seen and and you know I
I mentioned this on on Twitter
and people keep talking about how
representation matters how the fact that
you had you know Phil Lamar playing a
black Green Lantern was the Green
Lantern for a generation of kids white
black brown yellow whatever you want to
have it
um and it definitely means something to
all this clearly to be picking up the
mantle from Phil
but even more than that for me it was
just everybody's a fan like everybody's
got a thing that they've loved a thing
they've loved since they were a kid and
to be able to work in a space where you
get to be part of that fabric part of
that story that you're passing down from
generation to generation and then to be
able to meet the guy you were a fan of
hoping the kids will be a fan of you
like it's it was this perfect just
seamless meshing of all of the things
that make Comic-Con special you know
being able to meet your Heroes being
able to be part of a lineage being able
to be in a place where everybody's there
because they love something and these
two guys who didn't know they were going
to meet at the top of the night finding
each other in a sea of people that is ew
party and having this brief moment of
just pure wonder and joy
um was the most adorable thing that I
saw and it made my show honestly
that's adorbs man that's awesome
um so great I saw uh Deacon our good
friend Brett deakin who always
uh provides us with uh 40x and Screen X
tickets when we do this at the scum and
villainy cantina
um you know he invites us to come see
screenings and he invited us to see Thor
love and thunder and I went with my kid
and Phil was there with his kid no yeah
he's he's a he's absolute magic and such
a sweet guy every time I see him he's
always like Kevin
fail
I just remember he did a voice in the
clerk's cartoon where he did a child and
it was so [ __ ] convincing and he's
talking about Jay
the character of Jay and why he's able
to play on the Little League team and
Phil goes he got left back a lot
and then I was like that's Samurai Jack
like
very very gifted
um what a magical con moment that you
had man that's very much so that's gosh
[ __ ] that happens at Comic-Con kids just
it's why we're so happy to be back man
like it's just being in that space being
with those people and I I will happily
go to a con and do whatever they tell me
I need to do I gotta I gotta test I got
a vax I gotta have proof of it I gotta
wear a mask happy to do all of it but
just to get all that again you know and
feel safe about it
100 I'd be more strict if I had to be
also I hate to rub it in because I know
the rest of the country you know maybe
didn't go to Comic-Con and had to deal
with [ __ ] sweltering heat as well
which was all over the news but
what a lovely San Diego it was
temperature wise like I was wearing that
[ __ ] long coat the whole time so you
know I was trying to stay on brand I'm
selling a picture Kid So Silent Bob's in
full display [ __ ] the purple coat here
comes the [ __ ] Silent Bob coat so
that you're sitting there going oh yeah
Clerk's three I better buy my tickets
save this motherfucker's career so I was
so appreciative that it wasn't [ __ ]
hot man like it was pretty temperate
down there in in addition to the only
thing that was really hot Mark was all
the Marvel action at Hall h
yeah man we we had some theories going
into it you know we're like well what
are we going to see it's like I'm sure
we're gonna see you know if I had to
guess which we did I'm sorry we're gonna
see a black panther 2 trailer we knew
that was gonna come I'm tired of the
internet believe in the internet
internet told me right before that like
oh Marvel's not gonna show much because
they got d23 coming up so they're gonna
save everything for that internet was
wrong internet said I'm an idiot Mark so
maybe they're wrong about that as well
um they they can't be trusted yeah I'm
starting to rethink everything why do I
believe everything I read on the
internet internet told me Henry Cavill
was coming to [ __ ] Comic-Con
no he did not that did not [ __ ]
happen in the least and [ __ ] so I'm
tired of the internet fool me once shame
on you fool me twice whatever the [ __ ]
but man oh man it was uh a con to
remember uh kids we got no sponsor
tonight so I'm gonna use this precious
real estate to sell some of my [ __ ] uh
not only of course am I wearing a sweet
Roosevelt's uh button down that we
debuted at Comic Con all the staff at
the movies pop-up was wearing big thanks
to Tin Roof Inn they were our home all
weekend cosplaying as the movies pop up
we sold so much [ __ ] food and booze
let me tell you something about
Comic-Con people they like to drink mark
they do we we encountered that once or
twice doing a podcast Chow Down and they
[ __ ] a drink yeah we were able to do
live shows at night and they were
serving food and Foods throughout it so
Tin Roof uh many many things uh thank
you to the good folks of the Roosevelts
you can get this on their website they
got other things as well spirit jersey
made cool shirts that we were selling
there we did a lot of business at the
pop-up in terms of merch thank you for
everybody that came out
uh if you're like man I get to go to
Comic Con and [ __ ] well I'm on the road
kids this weekend I'm a Galaxy con me
and Jay and the clerk's kids [ __ ]
Brian Jeff
Trevor uh right there in uh the Carolina
the northern
Carolina
uh Raleigh
you know like [ __ ] the Durham Bulls
man remember that movie I do
um so come on out you get tickets at
ceasemon.com and then a few days after
that is my uh 52nd birthday Mark
um on August 2nd me and Jay are going to
be back east
so we're doing an event at Jay and
Silent Bob's secret stash where we take
pictures with everybody during the day
and then at night we do a Jay and Silent
Bob good old episode concept of the
birthday event this year is called 100
Years of Jay and Silent Bob which is
confusing to some let me sum up the
thesis Jay turned 48 in June I turned 52
in August on August 2nd 100 Years of
Jane Silent Bob uh good tickets come on
out see the good old show because we
showed the first five minutes of Clerks
three in Hall age played like [ __ ] a
charm I would not be surprised if I can
we played that at the James I Bob get
old show ladies and gentlemen we're
going to do that at the Atlantic movie
house
um I am
I used to go to as a kid so in any event
August 2nd tickets at cspod.com if you
want to come out for me and Jay's
birthday technically my Jay's birthday
but my birthday Jay's celebrating it
because he was in June Jayden's on about
100 Years of James Allen Bob tickets at
seasmod.com or Galaxy Con tickets also
at cspod.com all right
you got anything you want to pump
[Music]
open up
um you uh let's dive in then kids on
Saturday uh Marvel had their panel first
time in three years last time they were
there I think wasn't that when they were
like they gave Jane Foster to [ __ ]
hammer and [ __ ]
they were pushing love and thunder and
uh and they announced they ended with
announcing blade
right yeah when hershela comes out
wearing a hat so this year was their
first year back in three years and they
did not [ __ ] disappoint bonus charge
of the imagination uh some people
suggested that they would show a few
things and then keep everything good for
G23
I mean I don't know what they're keeping
for d23 because I feel like they showed
us an awful lot we'll get into the
trailers but let's talk about the phases
they announced all of phase five and
then just for shits and [ __ ] Giggles
Kevin foggy told us what the first film
of phase six was gonna be
which is the Fantastic Four and then he
revealed the [ __ ] final two phases a
final two films of phase six which are
Avengers movies one of them is called
they're both coming out in the same
[ __ ] year Avengers the Kang Dynasty
and then the second one is Avengers
colon Secret Wars
on November 7th of 2025. a reason to
stay the [ __ ] alive I'm hiking Runyan
Canyon every [ __ ] day because now
there's a goddamn reason to live Mark uh
they just announced today that the Kang
Dynasty gonna be directed by the guy who
directed Shang Chi correct right Dustin
Daniel critten congratulations on Shang
Chi it was a wonderful flick I'm sure
he'll do great with Kang Dynasty they
have not announced the secret Wars
director have they or director they have
not and we know for a fact that the
russos have been saying like oh we'd
come back for that what do you think the
chances are that we're getting another
Russo Brothers Marvel movie
I mean I I'd never count on Marvel I
never think that it's impossible
um it depends if they can take time away
from building a gray-man universe
um
which apparently they are sequels and
spin-offs and the like the Netflix film
The Gray Man that the Russo Brothers
directed from their uh came from their
agbo agbo production company
um I guess was [ __ ] huge his number
one movie on Netflix but that goes
without saying but they announced today
that they're they're definitely doing a
sequel the idea was always this would
kick open a franchise so for them to be
like we're doing it again with some of
the most expensive [ __ ] people in the
business means that it must
yeah you know and it's it's it's always
hard to tell what well means for Netflix
but well enough that they want to do it
again and they want to spin off
characters and you know who knows what
those spin-offs look like if there's a
TV version if there's a straight up
Netflix series version if it's all going
to be features who knows but they those
Russo boys are going to be busy in the
in the gray world for a while
but
you never know and also this is not till
when is it 20 35 No 20 35
25. I'd wait until then if I had to
thank God the gods of Marvel won't make
us wait that long 13 years for another
Avengers movie I'm I'm [ __ ] I look I
didn't even know we were ever promised
another Avengers movie
so I'm like what [ __ ] right on man
I'll wait as long as it takes and it's
not that long away and they've also like
told us the titles none of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] like last time we were like oh what
are they gonna call it and [ __ ] they
dumped a lot of information the fact
that they told this when Fantastic Four
is happening that it is happening was
[ __ ] that is happening as well yeah
so do you have a graph up for phase five
um I have the names of everything in
Phase five but I can easily pull up
the release dates too let's look
horrible phase five
so yeah I always introduce when you're
talking and then you didn't talk and I
let the show go [ __ ] quiet see what
happens so phase five begins in February
2023 with Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania all right so hold on
February 2023
is July 2022 August September October
November December January February we're
only seven [ __ ] months from this
yes we are
that's it then wait
the secret Invasion on TV what is step
one what's the first movie and or first
thing in Phase five
and man in the Watts
phase five
right the Kang phase
and I saw that trailer so let's stop and
talk about that real quick we'll do them
in in order of how they're coming at us
and [ __ ] uh I was uh backstage of course
as previously mentioned and will be
mentioning for the rest of my [ __ ]
life
um the trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP
uh quantumania was uh insanely loudly
received everyone was very excited in in
the hall
so it was tough to hear some of the
dialogue uh backstage
but we got a look at Bill Murray
um doing what I'm not sure I don't know
who he's playing I don't think they said
but I was there and I was watching the
trailer and I was like did I just
[ __ ] see Modoc and then they
confirmed Peyton Reed right after the
trailer was like yeah that was Modoc
like so far in there and they're not
hiding it and he looked [ __ ] up
[ __ ] not [ __ ] up bad [ __ ] good
it was just like holy [ __ ] I just can't
believe we're in that world man it's one
thing that uh Patton Oswald does a Modoc
cartoon and [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] bringing this Modoc into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe like
will wonders never cease
um but like the big [ __ ] draw of the
trailer was uh the voice over by Kang
himself the whole time or you know we
met a variant of him what was he called
the last one or something like that he
who remains he who remains
um and in this trailer I'm pretty sure
this is not that guy I'm pretty sure
this is the Kang that we're gonna be
with all throughout phase five and
there's a moment where like Scott
there's some really cute moments in in
the trailer like he wrote a book and
[ __ ] like that about saving the world
and whatnot but when he sees he's in a
scene with Kang and he says something
like I'm an Avenger
and I you know I could have sworn that
the next line would be like and I'm a
conqueror you know and then but instead
they they did something even more
[ __ ] dark man he goes I'm an Avenger
and he goes you're an Avenger and then
he steps out of the showers was Jonathan
um
the major steps out of the shadows and
you're like is he gonna have the [ __ ]
face mask of the headgear but it pretty
much looks like he he liked him
and he says you're an Avenger he goes
have I killed you yet [ __ ] it's
something like that [ __ ] like Swang
like really dark just like that's [ __ ]
up so I feel like you know Ant-Man and
Ant-Man and the WASP wonderful family
friendly films feels like some dire [ __ ]
is gonna happen in Quantum Mania it
feels like the cutesy title does not
belie the danger that is forthcoming
um yeah it looked [ __ ] pretty good so
that kicks off phase five in February
yes
February 17 2023
then what's next in the phase five
um secret invasion the uh the Nick Fury
TV show saw a trailer for that has that
been released yet the trailer no
the only one they released was uh was
was Black Panther and [ __ ] you're gonna
release one Jesus released that it was
[ __ ] epic and amazing uh I saw of
course everything so I saw the trailer
for
um secret Invasion and it was not what I
thought it would be
uh I thought it was going to be light
this is [ __ ] like conspiracy theory
time very very driven very Espionage
almost like
um
Captain America Two as that kind of free
days in The Condor feel to it who who's
you know [ __ ] who can you trust kind
of thing
um gripping not not the trailer I was
expecting and then you know in the
trailer of course we get to see Sam
Jackson
uh
I I don't know if they spoil we get to
see Sam Jackson we'll just leave it at
that
lots of them as well um so that was that
was a gripping Trail and [ __ ] and they
showed the whole cast like at one point
you can see Emilia Clark said her name
from uh
um and then Olivia
um Saturday Goldman yes
um
and homeboy who you know played the
skrull in cap Marvel was like good eyes
Ben mendelsohn oh [ __ ] I love that
guy what a great actor
um wonderful [ __ ] trailer man like
did not disappoint made me [ __ ]
excited uh you know it's not like I I
like those Ant-Man movies but that's not
one that I was like I got a [ __ ] and
by the end of that trailer I was like
Jesus man that just jumped to the top of
the [ __ ] list I was like you made the
list [ __ ]
I saw Peyton Reed backstage I'm a kind
of like a director nerd so I was like
um all right so what's next so secret
Invasion then Guardians 3 in May
all right let's stop talk about the
Guardians trailer uh hands down the
absolute [ __ ] highlight of Comic-Con
for me and I say that as a guy who
showed the first five minutes of his
movie and it was insanely warmly
received and and welcomed um
it's scored to the Flaming lip song Do
You Realize which is a pretty emotional
affair to begin with uh since we know
that this is the third and final outing
for the Guardians there's already motion
there uh packed in
um his visuals continue to grow and stun
not like they needed to grow but like
he's doing [ __ ] here he's not done
before beautiful things
um that match that music so well
um
there's
there's a sense of finality to it all
um I saw Adam [ __ ] Warlock
who looked amazing uh we saw of course
all the Guardians uh they teased a
storyline involving the Gamora from the
different timeline and Peter which looks
like Star-Crossed heartbreakingly good
like she has a moment where he you know
he talks about like who she was to him
who Gomorrah was and she's just like not
cold or shitty but she's just like I'm
I'm not that person and you're like oh
my God but
holy [ __ ] the the one of the main story
lines apparently is all about rocket and
they include
what looks like what could only be
flashbacks to his origin how he became
and there's one [ __ ] shot that
destroyed
the room destroyed me my [ __ ] kid who
was right next to me I talked about it
on the panel the whole H panel which is
up on my YouTube Channel right now
um it is
heart [ __ ] breaking
shot of a scared Rock first a hand is
coming in at him and then they cut to
him and he's kind of shrinking back with
scared baby eyes
bro I'm getting [ __ ] emotional just
thinking about it now oh my God it was
so [ __ ] beautiful it's only two
minutes of what promises to be over a
two-hour movie and all they needed was
that one shot they could have just put
up that those two [ __ ] shots put up
the release date and would have [ __ ]
brought the the room uh to their feet it
was uh beautiful simply [ __ ]
beautiful and I know a couple years ago
there was a minute where it looked like
we might not have a James Gunn finale to
the Guardians of the Galaxy and thank
God we did because if this is what he's
been saving like
it's just beautiful beyond words dude I
was bawling over a [ __ ] talking
raccoon
like
that's what a great Storyteller can do
can make you care about
one of the most ridiculous characters in
the pantheon of of of uh the Marvel toy
box and still
my God it just ripped hearts out with
that one shot Alone movie looks [ __ ]
phenomenal like just phenomenal so that
is when
that is May May 5th 2023 so we're in
July so August September October
November December January February March
April
10 months away [ __ ]
or not might as well have a [ __ ] baby
hey bamf man's here everybody give it up
for Banff man so some of us didn't get
to go into the room didn't see Guardians
what I really need to know is was baby
rocket cute enough to piss piss off Joe
Dante
[Laughter]
I can't imagine I can you know I don't I
can't imagine anyone will be like
somebody stole this it's just you know
he's just a little raccoon okay good to
know baby baby Yoda or grogu
was like a [ __ ] marketing
breakthrough like it just did when we're
like we've seen everything Star Wars
could do though like you ain't seen
Little Star Wars and then
I don't think we'll see his like again
in this lifetime
um this was just you know he's adorable
but like he's a baby raccoon what I see
from that shot though
is like he's not a [ __ ] talking space
raccoon
wow yeah I guess I have no information
based that on other than the shot I saw
but for the first time in my life
because in the movies you know he talks
about first off he doesn't know he's a
raccoon and he isn't you know [ __ ]
know about Earth or he only knows about
Earth from quill but and again this is a
complete conjecture on my behalf some of
the imagery made it seem like
you know
maybe he's from Earth I don't know
yeah I mean he also will never say that
he's an actual raccoon
or he's just a species that happens to
look like a raccoon
good very well James James Gunn on stage
teed it up so nicely I guess it was
maybe he didn't Tee It Up it was
afterwards because we'd seen it and he
talked about something I'm gonna ruin it
but it's not ruin it but not get it as
well as he did it
um he talks about like he's he was
always fascinated with rocket because he
was like I I think he would be the
loneliest
individual in the galaxy and like even
now I'm getting like [ __ ] choked up
when he said his brother too was uh is
Sean Sean yeah Sean again that [ __ ]
guy who's so good at the end of [ __ ]
Guardians too when the ravager's funeral
shows up and he's like yeah one of my
favorite moments in movie history one of
my favorite performances and [ __ ] he got
he was on stage everybody gets a moment
to talk and he said this really [ __ ]
sweet thing about working with his
brother and he got choked up and
emotional man like oh
it was great it was you could tell they
all [ __ ] love each other those kids
man they create a family I was texting
with James Gunn he texted me before to
be because I keep saying some [ __ ] about
the trailer online good [ __ ] and he was
like you were too kind and stuff and
that is one of the things I love about
this my job is that you can [ __ ]
interact with people who make the [ __ ]
that you love and like [ __ ] tell them
like oh my God like I want weeds deep on
that [ __ ]
trailer from memory for heaven's sakes
so
that was magical uh that trailer
absolutely was the highlight of
Comic-Con for me I can't wait to see
that all right what's next on the
timeline
um summer 23 brings us Echo
the spin-off from Hawkeye I'm ready I'm
ready to receive uh you know they set
her up in uh
uh Hawkeye as you said and uh you know
David Mack character
she was created in the run right after
my Daredevil run
um and we're getting
we knew we were getting Daredevil and
Kingpin in that but now we know
the Daredevil was getting a whole last
[ __ ] show
called born again we don't have details
I wonder if it is
about boarding
we'll get there
all right so wait so back to yeah where
were we on the timeline here Echo summer
23 as is Loki season two in summer 2023.
Loki season two is 22. when the [ __ ] is
wakanda forever
or kind of forever is this November what
kind of forever ends phase four that's
the finale of phase four we'll finish
stop talking about that all right keep
going with phase five since we're in it
yeah so Loki season two is summer 23
July 28th 2023 is the Marvels
which we got a taste of at the end of Ms
Marvel I mean people here Everybody
Knows by now but [ __ ] Captain Marvel
showed up at the end of the show
um so yeah I look forward to that
because I love that [ __ ] Miss Marvel
show my God it was so good yeah so we'll
get it's the sort of triumvirate of Ms
Marvel Captain Marvel and then Monica
Rambo
who we meet yeah in one division yes I
think her character is called Spectrum
um in this iteration but in the comics
would eventually be one of the captain
Marvels one of many Captain Marvels
what a world we live in I I look I like
this iteration of the Matrix this is
nice
um what's after that Mark
uh well I'm I'm less enthused with this
version of The Matrix but at least the
the pop culture is not bad oh no the
movie's good
uh November 3rd 2023 will bring blade
so that is over a year from now
yes have they started over here
I think I think they might have just
begun production
can't wait do you think it's gonna be
our
uh you know they they have definitely
been leading us to up to the the
threshold of our rated Marvel content
and so there's no reason to believe that
it wouldn't be if they wanted it to be
it doesn't have to be but it'd be great
if it was oh my God
um can't wait for that then what we
didn't we saw no previews of that or
anything obviously yeah sometime in Fall
23 we will get iron heart
we saw our first [ __ ] we got our
first look at Riri and the uh
in the uh wakanda forever trailer
yep
[ __ ] forges out the iron heart that
was dope what do you think do you think
how does she cross over do you think she
gets there remember at the end of black
panther they were like we're reaching
out and doing programs in the United
States
do you think that's where she comes from
or is she meant to be wakandan
you know I don't I don't know I mean
that in the book she's an American but
totally but you know in the movies they
like to remix and stuff like that right
um it would it would be it would be
lovely if she remained an American who
gets welcomed into the bosom of wakanda
when I watched the trailer that was the
vibe I got I was like oh [ __ ] she's one
of the people that they found by by like
reaching out so like at the end of black
panther that'd be very cool there's uh
we'll we'll deal with the Black Panther
trailer in a minute because we got a
deep dive on that that's how we'll end
what else is going on in this phase
um in Winter 23 we will get Agatha coven
of chaos great title I like that better
than AG of the House of Harkness I think
coven of chaos is fun very multi
Multiverse of Madness very much so
um then in Spring of 2024 Daredevil born
again
which we you saw me jizz over before but
let's add to that conversation Mark how
many episodes are we getting
um the last I saw 18 episodes
what did we do to deserve this blessing
because I want to keep doing it again
and again 18 [ __ ] episodes and that's
a whole ass that's like do you think
they're doing that's like a regular TV
series bro that's a regular TV show it's
not you think they're doing half hours
or 45 minutes or
I I you know who knows you know I feel
like they're probably hour Longs but
they can do whatever they want did they
do a similar
storyline in season three of Daredevil a
kind of uh born again-ish kind of thing
didn't they dismantle his life a little
bit in season three maybe they did they
did I mean not quite to the extent of
the comics but they they definitely did
Lean
back into the Catholic guilt of of Matt
Murdoch and you know there was a there
was a nun character who plays uh a big
role in sort of rehabilitating him and
putting him back on his feet
um
yeah so like it's it's been
the the well has been dipped into before
but I don't think the well is empty and
it was it was it Kingpin last time or no
he was kind of gone by that point
right no they brought him back in I
think I think Kingpin takes took a back
seat for season two
um being in jail he was in jail right
and then he gets sprung I remember the
breakout episode where he's in talking
about the Good Samaritan
yeah I'm just like I am I said I'm the
[ __ ] evil stranger and the [ __ ] oh
God that was so good
um
18 episodes Jesus
can't wait all right what's after that
Charlie Cox coming back [ __ ] uh
yo doing it [ __ ] we might get a real
born again man or close enough [ __ ]
May 3rd 2024 brings us Captain America
New World Order
and that's uh Sam Wilson's debut
in the indeed particular role uh of
Captain America we know much about that
um what we know is that it's uh it was
written at least in part by Malcolm
Spellman who was the head writer on the
Falcon Winter Soldier TV show
and it's now being directed by Julius
Ona who did the Cloverfield paradox
um but that's about it we don't know
anything beyond that
uh in chat they're telling me uh it's
the the ill intent I am the ill intent
but Vincent that's what Kingpin that was
a [ __ ] Wicked scene look that whole
Daredevil series was [ __ ] fantastic
um not to you know mention that [ __ ]
hallway fight sequence alone that's
fairly legitimate
um so Disney plus they got their work
cut out from Megan uh they got up there
there's a there's a bar that they gotta
hit but 18 episodes [ __ ] man I give you
more than enough time to hit that
[ __ ] bar and you got all the same
players
you got those magical actors and [ __ ]
and Disney plus has not let me down yet
with any of these Marvel shows I don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says so I'm
locked and loaded man you see at the end
of the [ __ ] She-Hulk trailer
[ __ ] the billy club shows up and they
cut the standing up and then they cut
away I was like oh backstage I was
screaming
um
to the Law and Order She-Hulk crossover
that they're setting up clearly nice
nice
um the last last chapter of phase five
is thunderbolts on July 26 2024.
um look I'm in I look forward as [ __ ] to
that but we did lose uh General Ross so
I guess it's not
it's not named after him no they'll
figure out a way to do it I'm sure
they're very clever over there
um all right so that's all of phase five
let's dip down phase four
uh Hey armor Wars nowhere in there
armor Wars was not dated but the thing
to remember is that when they put up the
slide for phase six
blank spaces they only gave us three
movies probably what's gonna happen at
d23 is They're Gonna Fill In A lot of
those slots
right so there's that stuff and there's
also the Disney has an investor call I
think in November where they also like
to to bring some dog and pony stuff out
and about
to be like hey look the state of the
union is great by the way here's another
nine things you didn't know were coming
um so yeah phase six will be filled out
it feels like by the end of this year
when does She-Hulk happen
She-Hulk happens in like three weeks
which is what happens in like early
August so that's also phase four that's
what's face for phase four then She-Hulk
and wakanda forever
see how can what kind of forever are the
the last two chapters of phase four
um yeah I look I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of
the She-Hulk trailer some people gave me
[ __ ] online for liking it and it's like
[ __ ] you I look I I'm a Comic Book Guy
when she turned and looked at the camera
and broke the fourth wall and talked I
was like
that's John Byrne man like [ __ ] John
Byrne when he did his she-rock run stole
that from Moonlighting which was popular
at the time and [ __ ] like was uh you
know it was a hit in the books it was
part one of the funnest part of the
books and when they show it in the
trailer she looks kind of you know
surprised by it
like that she broke the fourth wall and
I know like you know fleabag was a huge
hit and she broke the fourth wall like
all the time but John Byrne and She-Hulk
did it so many years ago that did my
heart good to see them honoring that
part of the mythology and I think that
the thing looks Charming as [ __ ] man
yeah and I think the VFX are getting you
know they're dominating they're getting
stronger yeah um that was why I heard
you don't have a Guardians trailer
release is because apparently there were
unfinished shots I personally didn't
notice anything but they're they're
unfinished VFX is I think why they
haven't released it yet is what I read
online if I had to guess and that's
again purely guess if they're doing that
d23 thing
they're probably gonna show it then and
maybe that's when we get it maybe it
comes out
but there I mean when is the movie come
out they're so far off it feels like
Guardians that's next year that's like
next week they got a minute to get there
they could put that trailer in front of
black panther too if they wanted to what
a great segue now let's talk about the
Epic that was the Black Panther wakanda
forever trailer uh Ryan coogler
um apparently uh has lost nothing as a
filmmaker gained everything oh my God
this movie is [ __ ] huge and looks
beyond accomplished not only are we back
to wakanda
they're also introducing the more and
and the atlanteans like
that's [ __ ] crazy man there's a lot
of movie there in the movie that they're
showing us in the trailer looks like
it's setting up a war between
wakanda and Atlantis the guy who plays
nemour
cannot character I think I believe his
name is did you see the [ __ ] Wings on
his feet both as a baby and as a grown
ass man
you see that [ __ ] screen accurate
outfit him he's wearing with the little
green trunks all of it was [ __ ]
perfect dude like the first mutant
there is
uh I mean the thing that I that I came
away with I mean I came in with so much
but
we often say and I've said more than
once so looking at these Marvel movies
well and while I do love them
sometimes it feels as if nothing is
really
nothing has any weight to it right like
especially when you get to the third Act
of some of these movies where it's just
CG punching CG
you know and they find a way to end the
movie and it's kind of exactly the same
place that they began in the movie these
characters like Thor love and thunder
ends with Thor just a happy dude you
know like I got this kid now cool that's
fine but it seems as if he was very much
the same characters he started as he
ended
um there's not a lot of weight there's
not a lot of permanence for some of
these movies
and then you get to to wakanda Forever
and it feels like it's nothing but
consequence
it's nothing but here are things that
have happened that are registering and
carrying weight you know the entire
first half of that trailer it's
permeated with this feeling of loss
you know and it's it's not as if we are
going to pretend that that just we don't
know where t'challa is we don't know
what happened to him I'm like no we're
we're 100 playing that t'challa is now
passed
you know and and it seems that I'm
reading between lines here but it seems
looking at at shuri that there's a
little bit of like there's a little bit
of Superman there of I can do all of
these things but I couldn't save my dad
I couldn't save my brother I could I can
do all of this science I can work
wonders with with the magic that is
wakanda
but I couldn't I couldn't save my
brother and so it just it there's this
feeling of heartbreak not just oh who's
that guy
come on in I was pointing to you I
wasn't saying get out special guest
oh hey
we were talking about did you see the
wakanda forever Charlie yeah you were
there backstage right he was there with
me too watching backstage he wasn't a
dope it was so good I like piano it's
just like snipped you know it pulls out
what like wrong movie not stick but yes
the flaws come out who do you think that
is we're gonna get into that
conversation later but who's wearing
that suit Wolverine no I'm just kidding
uh I don't know I don't know honesty I
wasn't sure were you there for all the
trailers you were there for the whole
panel I wasn't there for the
I'm right at the end right you saw that
yeah yeah they showed it twice in a row
yeah
yeah playing yeah it was it was the
feeling there was great because you
could see the emotion on the cast and
stuff it was pretty amazing there it is
right there there's the question oh yeah
and then I wake up
um the uh the boy here who was a 48 year
old man I think 48 now yes yes yes
because 100 Years of James alabab on
August 2nd uh was on the clerks 3 panel
with me after the marble panel and did a
very like funny it wasn't even a bit it
was just like purely authentic where he
was talking about
um you know he's like we got our hands
and footprints in the cement of the
Chinese Theater like back in 2019. he
was like now I want to get a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and then the
third is a wax figure
that was like a wax [ __ ] figure who
told you that was the [ __ ] Pinnacle
and he was like I went to Danny Trejo's
wax figure ceremony and he was next to
Obama and the Golden Girls [ __ ]
that's when you know you made it right
when you're next to the Golden Girls and
Obama and area Ariana Grande too oh [ __ ]
you left her off the list so that's what
he's gonna do working hard to become a
wax figure anyone out there these are my
things wax star fortnite skins fortnite
skins so listen if Madame Tussaud
herself if you're out there listening
here's a guy who definitely wants to be
a human candle
it must be made of wax how's the wax
right there
oh look at this we have another Special
Care another special guest come on over
and say hi this is the young Logan Muse
named for
Wolverine Weapon X
they just went swimming man yeah we just
went swimming she's hungry so we're
gonna go but thank you guys have a great
day
and Janice Jen is in the room if you go
knock on a door she'll come out and give
you a hug
bye kiddo
so adorbs
and she's adorable too
that and right there like [ __ ] that
little image that you saw that little
slice of
[ __ ] Americano whatever you call it
family
brought to you by the fact that that
dude was able to get over his demons
over 10 years ago there was a time where
we didn't know what you know [ __ ]
Jay's future was I did The Walking
[ __ ] billboard for being able to turn
[ __ ] around man like and one of the best
dads [ __ ] that honestly the best dad
I've ever encountered in my entire life
made me like you know by the time he had
his kid my kid was already grown up
grown up and [ __ ] seeing him with his
kid made me go like [ __ ] like I should
have been that kind of dad he's
absolutely [ __ ] wonderful weather and
stuff but it's a there's a lesson here
kids if you're fighting something he
used to fight [ __ ] you know
addictions and [ __ ] his chance you work
hard you can put it behind you and
[ __ ]
is joyful dude all he ever wanted in
life was to have a family you know he
didn't really never knew his dad was his
mom was in and out of jail he longed for
stability as a kid you know good news is
it created a a wonderful sense of humor
[ __ ] big-hearted guy but he had a
hard life growing up and [ __ ] and he
always wanted like a family of his own
that's why it clung to mine early on and
[ __ ] like some sense of stability
normalcy that kid is his entire [ __ ]
world like it's beautiful to watch
they're they're besties they [ __ ]
hang out and [ __ ] like that it's cute
anyway back to [ __ ] morning
um yeah I mean it just there's there's
there's a very tangible sense of loss in
the beginning of that trailer and then
the idea that loss doesn't wait you know
you the real world will intrude when it
decides to intrude and so
Queen Ramona who is like 100 still
grieving the loss of her son still has
to lead wakanda against the fight of its
life which seems to be you know an
invasion from beneath the ocean from a
from a tectonic event happening off the
African Coast as we were teed up in
Avengers uh infinity War
um I mean I it and it just looks
and it looks real you know like we we've
seen so many just VFX Fantasia's that
feel like they're just made of candy
corn
and like when you see the shot of a a
whale from underneath and guys are
holding on to it like this is the
trailer that that Avatar movie wanted to
be
like this is the one that's evocative
and and has nothing but you know it's
it's teasing it's promising more than
it's just showing
um and I just and and the music kind of
broken me you know it's like No Woman No
Cry
into into Kendrick
into everything's gonna be all right
it's just my God
the the use of no woman of Christ saw
some people being like why would they
use this I'm like what are you [ __ ]
crazy like that's what the song's about
it's about female strength that's the
thing that blew me away about the the
entire trailer and the story that seems
to be shaping up is how
insanely female forward the whole thing
is when you remove
t'challa as he's been removed in the
storyline you're left with it like a
kingdom full of women and I think
I think you know whatever black panther
made I think this makes as much if not
even a little more
because at the end of the day like I'm
I don't want this to be politicized or
whatever but like
is a movie for everybody but oh my God
women are going to love this movie
it probably even more so than they loved
black panther I is my guess like it just
my kid and my daughter responded to it
in a way that like I respond to this
stuff like my wife weeps watching that
trailer we watched it backstage and they
ran it twice the Black Panther Trail the
wakanda forever trailer
um then we watched it last night here on
big TV watched it a few [ __ ] times
the trailer itself then went back and
watched sections then went back and
watched it with the [ __ ] closed
captioning on them went and watched one
of those videos where somebody breaks it
down and [ __ ] like that and my wife's
balling the whole time I'm telling you
man this movie is something special
um and it's it's going to connect with
anyone who suffered loss and we all have
everybody [ __ ] suffers loss and stuff
it was profound it was big made me feel
small as a filmmaker but I always do but
man oh man I was just like look at this
like
faced with
you know the unenviable heartbreaking
task of trying to continue telling that
story without Chadwick
um Ryan coogler based on that trailer
alone
may have [ __ ] taken us in a direction
perhaps we weren't necessarily going to
go and it looks fantastic
yeah I mean I I remain I remain of the
opinion
that inshallah deserves to be a
character that persists in the Marvel
Universe because I do think that it's
important for young black kids or young
kids in general to have a t'challa in
their lives and so for that character
teachers vanish completely
you know I'm not going to say it's a
disservice but would be a shame
um but I also understood completely the
desire on Ryan Cooper's part on Kevin
feige's part on the entire filmmaking
squads part to not rush to that that
they they wanted to have the moment to
grieve and to let us all grieve the loss
of this man and it feels very much as if
this is a movie that's leading us in a
sort of spiritual journey of
understanding and processing and coming
to terms with finally cinematically the
loss of Chadwick Boseman like there will
probably be some point down the line
where I mean we are live in the
Multiverse multiversal Saga there's
going to be a secret Wars movie where
there is a t'challa From Another
Dimension from another Multiverse From
Another Earth who crashes into the story
played by a different actor you know
that's that that's what a Multiverse
gives you the opportunity to have but to
take a movie to say goodbye to that guy
like it's it's a profound statement
class Beyond class and also I'm telling
you they're going to be rewarded for it
like I don't know what he had planned
obviously uh for a black panther sequel
had Chadwick live but like
they did not shirk from from a challenge
and they may have made something
incredibly special
because of that loss you're right they
may just be taking a whole entire movie
to to grieve and breathe and it looks
for lack of a better description [ __ ]
special you just tell the ones that have
some magic about them I I think it's
going to break records man because I
think it's going to live in people's
[ __ ] hearts
um if that that look
we all know you know uh trailers uh can
be misleading I don't think there's any
I think that trailer plays a hundred
percent [ __ ] authentic it is dripping
with authenticity
so I think we're getting not a false
bill of goods but whatever the [ __ ]
opposite of that is if you feel when you
watch that trailer like as much as
people do what my wife crying I get
emotional imagine what the [ __ ] how
devastating the entire feature is going
to be
yeah
emotionally
yeah I don't I don't know how one
prepares for that other than we're gonna
be in that place in about six months
five months is this just November
like it is not a long time to wait
for like four months we're gonna be
there yeah
um what's it let's speculate can we nerd
out for a little bit
sure
um we'll bring on our guest then we will
I know but I don't want to nerd out with
the guests because I don't want the
guests to get in trouble I thought about
this yes he needs to be prepared and
insulated from our nonsense but yes
absolutely we'll talk about craft with
the guests we're not going to sit there
and be like oh who do you think that is
I don't want this cat to lose his job
um all right so here's my uh big
question uh who's wearing the suit at
the end
I mean they're they're there are but so
many contenders right so many
possibilities
um Baku is a possibility Winston Duke
and we see him in the trailer
um
man like a [ __ ] Sky it's not getting
the more he launches himself at that I
saw him back Steve Winston Duke and I
know him a little bit but once again I
was like I'm not gonna
like the last thing anybody needs when
they're like I'm going out in front of 6
000 people it's like hey remember Silent
Bob
I just I stayed I hung back and [ __ ] but
I saw him at the ew party because he's
easy to see because he's actually six
and a half feet tall he's very tall he's
a big man
um so it could be him could be shuri
which you know there was a ton of
speculation that she would take on the
mantle that was when I saw the trailer I
immediately turned to Harley and I was
like that's that's sure in the suit and
then it wasn't until you know I watched
it a couple more times and then people
online were like
I don't know if that's
sure like suddenly it occurred to me
that I don't [ __ ] know like in the
comics she became black panther at one
point but yeah who knows what they're
gonna do now there are shots in that
trailer which lead me to believe
it's shuri but that's what trailers do
they misdirect and they put things
together in a different way so that when
you see the final product you're
surprised by things so it could be that
it ain't sure what do you think I mean
it it could also be Riri Williams like
this could be a temporary thing this
could be a this is the suit that she
builds using what was lying around using
the material she had in wakanda left
um it could be the proto-iron heart suit
potentially you know we only saw but so
much of this thing now there's also a
faction online which I think is
fanciful because I think we would have
heard something but now but hey man I'm
up for it and [ __ ] someone will like uh
they're gonna bring back killmonger
and I was like if they are I don't think
it's in this movie because how would we
not have heard about Michael B Jordan
returning this soon unless it was one of
the best kept secrets of all time
um
did you good at it like when Marvel when
Marvel wants to keep a secret they can
keep it secret
and so I mean Michael B was in Atlanta
making Creed Three they're shooting this
in Atlanta like it's
it wouldn't be the craziest idea to
imagine that for a scene or two like
you're not getting it's not a killmonger
movie but if you wanted to pretend that
like well we never saw him die if if
they go to uh what is the not the green
belt but the where he won the ancestral
plane The ancestral plane
if if if let's say Surety is you know
has to find the version of the flower or
makes it because she's genius and
ingests and goes to the ancestral plane
there's a good chance just like
killmonger saw his dad that we might see
killmonger there I think it's a heady
steady bet that we if we see Michael B
Jordan that he would be there I I don't
know that he puts on the suit I don't
that never occurred to me but I'm not an
imaginative man I mean three Mark so
that's proof that I'm you know my
imagination is small I I I'm not the
alone here I know a lot of people online
feel the same way but
my new guess
trailer opens
not with
Surety
who's it open with Nakia
not yeah maybe I mean
in a world of symmetry you open with a
character
and you close a character you see their
Arc now we don't know a lot about the
movie so
we can't you know know that that's the
case but
that was you know I was like oh maybe
that's why we start with Nikia so that
they can end with Nikia and she was a
warrior remember like [ __ ] well she
was a spy Spy but like she she
didn't [ __ ] a boot up
um and there's also another candidate
that that even though the Black Panther
is often the head of state it's not
usually it's not always that thing
but there's no reason that can't be
Angela Bassett in that way the other
[ __ ] thing I thought man especially
when she did give her that moment in the
trailer where she's talking about like
you know I've given my whole family
because you're like well wait a second
where's shuri you know and then I was
like what if it's her man that big
[ __ ] dope yeah yeah
that'd be amazing I mean that's weird
about those guns the first trailer like
they got it's such a wealthy proposition
they got here that the first trailer
they could just go completely emotional
but the next trailer they can start
playing the shell game of like who is it
who's behind the mask like they got a
mystery that they could be selling Us in
addition to war with Namor which is like
a movie I'd watch in and of itself
movies [ __ ] pack this kid is [ __ ]
gifted now I saw him backstage too
um and he was uh very
there's there seemed to be a spiritual
moment with him and his group as well
like
same with James and the and the
Guardians they're they're close these
cats and those cats are super close and
and they talked about on stage going
through the process of making this with
that I think uh
uh Leticia said like without big bro or
something like that it was kind of
emotional Big Brother
um you could tell they've all been
through something and did something
special
you know in in the absence of their
their fallen comrade magical [ __ ]
trailer
who do you think is who do you think is
wearing the suit
uh I'm I'm I'm going to I'm going to not
vote for who's ran a suit I I would love
it I mean of the of the candidates that
we spoke of
I mean Angela Bassett would just like
just blow the [ __ ] doors off
The Rage with which he could fight too
all that loss
uh the queen black panther hell yeah
um well there's there here
somebody asked me in the chat they're
like what are the breakdown video you
watch uh the new rock stars if I may
plug somebody else did it break down the
trailer and they showed us he's going
into like in the beginning when they're
all white it's like a funeral procession
they're holding his helmet as they're
heading toward what in the new rock
stars they conjecture might be the green
belt because it was beyond that
like what looked like a tomb and it's
all green inside or whatever but clearly
that's where they're going to to bury
them or what's left of them or something
or
memorialized t'challa on one side
there's the first
the the guy who was the first black
panther who took the herb first the
flower and [ __ ]
what is it the shinga I believe is his
name and Bast is at his feet
and on the other side they have
um like a woman
and I guess there's Bost and there's
another
lion slash feline cat God which they
mentioned
in Civil War when t'challa is talking
about my people believe that when you
die you go to and he references vast and
I forget the other God's name in that
video from the new rock stars they were
suggesting that see The woman there and
see how there's also a cat better SEC
met somebody in
in a chat segment
um they're saying there's a woman and
there's segment at her feet and if you
look at the woman she's dressed very
much like Angela Bassett I'm not saying
that's Angela Bassett but there's
already setting up the notion of like
there's a female version of this like
right there too if the new rock stars
are to be believed and I think they do
some pretty good Deep dive video work
man a guy Eric Voss very entertaining
plug plug for the new rock stars
don't click over yet wait till we're
done and then go [ __ ] watch their
video yeah because I do want to know you
know what it what it's like as as you
know when you get handed what has to be
you know 200 minutes of Unfinished film
and you're like okay now you got to go
and make a trailer
you got you gotta you gotta pick and
choose and decide you know I'm sure in
consultation with filmmakers and
whatever but how how are we going to to
put our first foot forward how are we
gonna entice a world how are we going to
enthrall an audience with uh with a
first look at wakanda forever
um let me tell you this
cutting a trailer you could be the
greatest filmmaker in the world man you
can't cut your own trailer
some have tried I'm not saying it's
impossible but cutting trailers is an
absolute art form unto itself it's
filmmaking
um just like when you're a filmmaker you
know you got cameras and film and sound
equipment and stuff and actors to help
you those are the resources that help
you make the film
uh of an editor of a trailer trailer
editor is a filmmaker as well they have
resources just like us it's just their
resources are a little more finished and
stuff but it doesn't mean that the job's
easier encapsulating what like look in
the case of uh wakanda forever what
seems like literally got to be over two
and a half hour Epic movie with a lot of
moving parts and story lines
and you could have gone any number of
ways and the path they chose the tone
that they picked
like has connected insanely well
everyone's talking about the use of of
No Woman No Cry and the and the uh
Kendrick Lamar song
so who does that who are The Magicians
behind that and are they paid as well as
they should be I consider myself an
editor but I you know I just it's easy
to edit a Kevin Smith movie because you
just shoot what you need and then cut
that together like it's difficult to be
a real editor and it's even more
difficult to cut trailers that is a an
art form and it's a it takes a [ __ ]
gift
then we say all that
because uh we got a guest ladies and
gentlemen I was hanging out on Twitter
before we uh
went a few hours ago and I saw a tweet
uh that was put up
uh by the editor of the wakanda forever
trailer he said like hey man I I cut the
Black Panther trailer and so I was
honored to cut this trailer too and
you know I love love the people who are
groving on it whatever paraphrasing
um
uh you know I'm a fan of good work kids
if you're exceptional at your job like
I don't give a [ __ ] if you're famous or
not I'm gonna blow you up I see an
opportunity and so I hit him up to just
be like this [ __ ] trailer is a work
of art like I forget what I tweeted
exactly but it's very complimentary and
then he responded and I saw my moment
and I was like oh [ __ ] we're about to do
a show and we're just gonna blow this
trailer anyway why don't you come on and
chit chat about it and mercifully he
said yeah now we're not gonna go into
the like hey man spoil Marvel movies
because we don't want the man to lose
his [ __ ] job kids so obviously I'm
going to talk about that we'll talk
about the past and we'll talk about this
present this trailer but mostly we're
going to talk about what it takes to
make a two-minute magic spell that makes
a [ __ ] want to live I saw that
trailer and I was like that gives me
[ __ ] a reason to live till November
um welcome uh to the show everybody
Andrew how do you pronounce your last
name
uh Higley Higley I was gonna say I
didn't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] it up well
welcome Andrew egley everybody thank you
so much man now Andrew do you work for
Marvel or trailer copper cutting company
uh currently I work uh for Disney Disney
[ __ ] all right that's right so Marvel
owned by dizzy so are you an uh I mean
clearly you're a world-class editor but
do you mostly cut trailers do you cut
features you've got TV shows what else
you got
um I just cut trailers for the past
Maybe be nine years I'm just a trailer
guy what an art form man look trailers
are my some of my favorite favorite
movies at the end of the day you can
count on a [ __ ] trailer it always
delivers the movie not so much case in
point go look at any Kevin Smith trailer
so much promise and then you see the
movie so much promise wasted so in many
ways like trailers are far uh more
engaging far far they deliver far more
joy than the movie ever does a trailer
cannot let you down it only builds your
anticipation and hope man so you got
that golden [ __ ] job of putting
together media that everybody [ __ ]
loves man you ain't got to deal with the
blowout later on when people like what
the [ __ ] happened the trailer was
amazing the movie's dog [ __ ] you're like
not my problem bro this trailer is uh
[ __ ] dazzling if they were paying
people
for quality of work somebody should be
marching you into an office right now
and giving you a hefty raise that
trailer is a trail I'm recording you
saying that and I'm going to take it
everyone listens to Kevin Smith
um I don't know who that is
um I'm telling you man the whole world
was waiting for this trailer
and you did not let the whole world down
like that's a lot of [ __ ] pressure
think about the amount of expectation of
people like I can't wait to see my first
look at wakanda Forever not only do you
stick The Landing you [ __ ] sword man
it's a beautiful piece of work how does
one go about starting
like you've got a movie what is there do
you get is there any guidance are there
like you could do this you could do this
don't do this these are the songs to use
tell us you know that that's a really
great question it's completely different
for every project you go to like I
started off with um more of a Art House
Indie house trailer park company uh it's
called Mark Malone Associates and a lot
of the products would you give us
examples of what you cut back in the day
oh back in the day
um triple nine the red band trailer uh
dope uh kicks a lot of smaller stuff you
know not I I didn't like you know really
get into a lot of big stuff until Disney
uh which I got into maybe five years ago
black panther was like the big thing
that kind of got me in the door and then
after that I did like
Star Wars trailers and like four or five
marble trailers now so it it's been it's
been like for me the past couple years
Star Wars and Marvel have kind of been
my thing uh bad things to have does that
yeah my God if you're gonna play with
the toys what great toys does that mean
the movies and the Disney Plus shows as
well yeah yeah so the thing I cut before
this was uh and or the teaser for Andor
um okay and I cut uh with my buddy Jason
and uh we cut the first Mandalorian
trailer which didn't show baby
we're like do not do not play with those
dailies Look Away
what is the uh what about let's take
black panther for example how do we get
to know Woman No Cry
um you know we got to that because Ryan
dropped it on our lap like it literally
it was Ryan and Ludwig uh I I don't know
how much you can say about this but uh I
locked a completely different trailer
before uh and we were all happy with it
and I was really excited about it
because the first film meant so much to
me personally like I met my wife working
on that movie and now we have a baby and
uh it just meant that first film was
just like everything to me you know like
went to Tech check at Comic-Con met Ryan
it was it was [ __ ] great and then uh
so to land this trailer for you know the
sequel and with all the weight and
everything with it meant a lot and then
we got a call saying uh Ryan
did a song with Thames and it's amazing
and we gotta rethink everything and
then that became this teaser and they
came together extremely quickly to uh
our team uh just a handful of really
dedicated people with a lot of love and
a lot of passion for this movie yeah
do you have a first conversation with
Ryan even before you guys are started
like what's the first thing that happens
do you just get footage and you go and
you start making like yeah right right
now it
is done for my department The Hive at
Disney and we get in dailies uh and I
kind of just like look through them and
a lot of times for these movies you know
before we're even assign them I just
like start digging and I'm because I'm a
fan I'm like everybody you know like I
want to know what's next I wanna I wanna
start being inspired by it all you know
and uh
uh yeah for this one it was just seeing
the imagery seeing uh everything that
basically things that respond you know
that people respond to in the teaser or
things that we respond to things that it
begins and ends with Ryan and uh
yeah man that that's you just kind of
start dwelling and uh going into it and
uh
I kind of collected maybe 40 minutes of
just visuals that I loved and
I you know I I tend to finish more
teasers than trailers because I'm all
about the atmosphere and the mood uh I I
pretty bad actually when it comes to
finishing the final trailer
story heavy and I'm I'm not that like
I'm all about the mood
so uh yeah man uh
we just kind of dug in with a lot of
stuff
and then once that song once we got that
song and I threw it to uh my man uh Dave
James Rossum and told him he's does
trailer music
and he put in Kendrick and we just said
hey let's repeat this and put it on top
there and like it just kind of cut
together like butter and I feel bad
taking any flowers for this [ __ ] because
it just feels very serendipitously like
put together and again it just begins
and ends with Ryan and then Ludwig and
then my composer and yeah I'm kind of
just along for the ride what uh now so
the way I understand it you're thinking
about the trailer the moment there's
footage for the movie
I'm thinking about it before usually I
mean especially like Marvel movies you
know we we know the characters we know
you know stuff that's happening I read
all the [ __ ] that you guys read I'm I'm
like you know really and luckily I have
a lot of access to stuff so I I
sometimes you get ideas you I there's
this term I like to use called uh build
a house around a kitchen sink and it's
like sometimes there's a line or just a
glare or a glance or some little [ __ ]
moment that I'm just like oh and that's
what the the entire trailer the entire
piece has to build around that moment
because that thing spoke to me somewhere
you know uh and sometimes you get that a
year before like you see anything you
know most of these trailers for Marvel
were put together pretty early
um or at least versions of them you know
and uh yeah yeah so it's not like in my
world the trailer is I wouldn't say an
afterthought but nobody starts working
on it until the movie is done and it
sounds like there they're like working
on a trailer simultaneously while
they're making the movie even before the
movie begins they're thinking about out
how they're going to present it to the
world man I love what you said about the
kitchen sink that is absolutely [ __ ]
brilliant right on yeah man I I like I
like to think of uh uh trailers as the
especially teaser trailers which are
more mood building the if you watched a
movie and then you fell asleep and you
had a dream about it the trailer is the
dream you had and uh I feel like that
captures like a and again it all starts
in this particular case it starts with
Ryan and then Ludwig figuring out that
song no woman to cry I I think uh you
know the movie's not done but it's it's
in uh it's gonna be [ __ ] great I
can't see you but you know you um so in
the do you
you don't do you you mentioned seeing
dailies so you don't have to wait until
they're like there you go watch it
you're seeing it as it comes together
does that take you as far back to even
the script like would you Circle
sometimes sometimes yeah sometimes we we
get the script um again like when I was
back at uh Mark Mullen and Associates
like I'm mostly just getting the final
feature you know like if we worked on uh
you know a small indie or uh an art
house film something lower than 50 Grand
uh 50 million you know probably just the
final feature and uh uh but you know
working at Disney house there are a lot
of privileges that come with that where
you can be more involved creatively with
uh the marketing team who are like the
best in the business like I just I don't
want to go anywhere it's great yeah what
uh do you have heroes in the trailer
cutting world or they're rocking holy
[ __ ] do I have heroes in the trailer
cutting board yeah man uh well it
started it started off with Mark Mullen
who who's uh unbelievable phenomenal uh
or he was really like a big inspiration
for me uh a good friend of mine JD
finary who has got some of the most
incredible pieces uh he helped me get
into the business and I I Adore
everything he does uh then there I I'm
kind of part of the crew that uh there
are a bunch of different ways to get
into the trailer editing business uh it
used to be you become an AE you do a lot
of grunt work and then you work your way
to prove yourself to become a junior
editor or a princess you know like that
um and then they're kind of like 10
years ago it was hey if you cut a lot of
fan stuff and put it on YouTube and you
got a rhythm like you can get a shot and
I was kind of part of that crew uh which
is really helpful and uh uh yeah there's
a lot of people in that career that I
admire
greatly greatly Joe Walden Jen hit
there's a whole lot a whole crew that is
just and these are like these are gifted
Artisans who's like they don't get the
sexy of like a credit on a trailer they
should remember I like in the beginning
MTV they didn't give directors credit
and [ __ ] 10 20 years in they were like
maybe we should credit the directors of
these things every trailer should be
like a signature at the end of it from
who cut it because I'm telling you man
it's like it's a gift and the people
that do it are an Elite Force that know
how to go into a movie and in the case
of like black panther clearly Ryan has
the goods but like I'm sure over the
course of your career you've had to make
trailers for movies where you're like oh
my God where you were actually able to
create something that wasn't necessarily
there like going with mood or feeling
um is that true
no it's totally not true
no no no no you're right you're right
but like honestly like you you I I get
into this thing where like I've never
disliked a movie I've cut is that right
it's not because I've been lucky and
only cut you know like a country percent
on Rotten Tomatoes I just like you you
it's like an absolute honor and
privilege to be able to work on
somebody's moving you know a lot of
times it's like everybody's pouring in
their life to it you know like just
think about what you did with clerks if
you had to hand that off and and give it
something and say okay you're
responsible for introducing this thing
that means so much to me and is the
story of my life and you're responsible
for
asking an audience to come in to get
people in I know who cut that trailer
this guy named Matthew Cohen dude no way
yeah trailer for clerks and he also cut
the trailer for Chasing Amy which was an
amazing trailer as well so I remember
like that was early in my career
obviously and the notion of somebody
cutting a trailer like I was like this
is my favorite part of [ __ ] movies
man like how does one do it and he cut a
wonderful [ __ ] trailer man like it's
I'm telling you I've always had nothing
but respect for traveling it's such a I
don't think a lot of trailer editors can
hate the movies they work on I mean some
there are some I'm sure that like can
turn it off and turn it on but like you
just gotta have to try to inject into
what if not what they achieved than what
they were trying to achieve and just
ride that wave with them as much as
possible okay Andrew you got a beautiful
soul behind you you got a bunch of
Hardcore media their physical media
what's that all about me I did it's like
over it's back here here it's over here
it's over there and yeah I I'm I'm my
wife is like it stays in this room it
doesn't go anywhere else you know uh I'm
all about the physical media and I have
a TV that I I every time I cut on
something I like uh put on inspiration
you know in the background to kind of
yeah what is uh and I know it's hard to
pick favorites but what is your favorite
trailer that you didn't cut
and uh my absolute favorite trailer is
uh Little Children the first trailer yes
it's a great yes bro you cut that
trailer [ __ ] no I didn't knock out that
trailer no no no
what he didn't cut it's your favorite
trailer great [ __ ] trailer
a dude I love that trailer so much I'm
totally blanking on on the man who cut
that I mean he worked for Mark Wallen
too and he left like the day I joined um
he ended up running a Focus Features
marketing department completely like
he's he's just such a master uh and he
also did social network uh that trailer
which is a great [ __ ] trailer piece
of art you know yeah yeah I just
remember the the sound of the coming
train and the bells in the distance as
the as the gate would close so that it
was just Majesty so good so good man
yeah what is the where does one go with
it Andrew like you mentioned some cat
who cut a trailer who then went over to
run focus is that what happens to most
trailer Cutters do they like become
heads of marketing departments um lot of
them do uh my uh Boston and a guy is
very responsible for this this piece he
Shepherd us through nbaison he was a
trailer editor he did The Dark Knight uh
like the one that everybody remembers
like the first one that really showed
the Joker yeah he you know like he did
that and then it was like golden ticket
you know but he he's worked at that time
and now he's like this amazing uh EVP at
Disney uh well he's still so will a guy
like that still like [ __ ] roll up the
sleeves and cut or is he like I left
cutting behind I think he's too busy but
I I I don't know man I bet Ryan was
googlers by the way you just do it you
know
because he's the one talking to him all
the time you know
where do where do you want to go with it
eventually like do you are you happy
exactly where are you like but what I
really want to do man I I I think I have
a theory that almost every trailer
editor is a failed filmmaker some degree
no I failed bro not failed a superior
[ __ ] filmmaker maybe yeah I mean I
I've been cutting trailers since high
school for like our little news uh
broadcast and stuff like I was the
president of the film club so would cut
trailers for that my I remember my
teachers to like this is a waste of time
what are you doing
and then I I you know went to film
School came to LA with dreams of being a
filmmaker and uh uh the thing I kept on
really realizing was like the thing I
was best at was cutting so
uh just cut a bunch of fan stuff and
then you know found it found a home here
what was the fan trailer that broke
through for you oh you know what it was
it was Looper so the way I did it was I
I uh worked for this company movie clips
which I don't know if you go online yeah
[ __ ] all the time yeah yeah pull out
the clips and then there's that music at
the end time right yeah that was like
the first solid job I had and uh and uh
they had a little production company and
they were like we want to be the first
place people go to get trailers and to
get the trailer content of movies uh on
the YouTube space and we need to figure
out how to get people here we don't this
was at a time where apples was getting
all the exclusives you know on their
site so they uh kind of said oh if you
make some fan trailers and just like
we'll post them as real ones so let's
just do it you know uh so I made a bunch
of fan trailers that
and then I ended up putting them on my
own website and um I got a job through
it uh because a buddy of mine JD
fernario I mentioned earlier he uh saw
it and he was like oh what trailer house
do you work for and I'm like none this
is called fan stuff you know uh but the
first one the one that really got me was
a fan trailer cut for Looper uh which
was split screen and it was like half of
it was all Bruce Willis and half of it
was all
um you know Gordon Joseph uh Joseph
Gordon-Levitt yeah and uh it kind of
played out and then it crossed and
weaved in between each other and stuff
and that came out like I was just using
footage from Like official clips and you
know the trailers that came out and uh I
remember I worked on Last Jedi and I
told Ryan Johnson about that I was like
you are responsible for me having this
career thank you so much because that
was the one that like the producers uh
called out and said oh we like this okay
we'll give you a shot you know it's
really cool if you just joined us uh
we're talking to Andrew how do you say
it again Andrew
um who cut amongst other things he cut
most recently the trailer for wakanda
forever the Black Panther sequel which
everybody [ __ ] loves he cut the first
black panther trailer
um we were just talking about the art of
trailer cutting and it is an art form
kids uh Andrew what are give me the five
favorite trailers of yours you ever cut
obviously black panther is there I was
yeah I would say uh what kind of forever
is probably my number one now just
because it just means so much personally
me then black panther are probably I
really really really liked shangshi the
teaser for shangshi uh I really liked
triple nine the red band trailer was a
big deal uh the
eternals teaser was a big deal for me uh
just because I I love clothes out and I
I love her vision did you hear that song
yeah it's so funny I nobody will ever
believe me that this is what happened
but it totally happened
I was like made a playlist of songs I
thought could match that movie while we
were getting in dailies and stuff and uh
um don't you know it's the end of the
world you know that that song I found it
and I was like oh you know that that
sounds cool because and honestly it came
from a space of like nobody's done like
a kind of 50s fun quirky thing with
Marvel before and it just felt good and
then literally we get the first feature
and it's in the movie and I was like
this is this is serendipitous I like if
we have to use that you know and uh yeah
so what what a weird coincidence man I
know so I can't really take credit that
I I I found it but I I swear to God I
did
when you you mentioned before like you
build the you find the kitchen sink and
build the house around it where is music
in it for you is that the first thought
or later on it is the beginning and end
it is everything like I I I you don't
have a cut without music uh I I
certainly don't know if I could start a
trailer without thinking of the impetus
of a song and when your trailer editor
kind of ruins you for enjoying music
because all you do when you hear
anything it's like what could I use this
for you know
has there ever been a song that you were
like listen this is perfect it's the
only one I can use and then they can't
clear it and he like son of a [ __ ] all
right fine dude that has happened so
many times either an artist doesn't
wanna and you know like it sucks for
when you're Disney because before it's
like we couldn't afford it you know like
and you try to throw around songs and
you can't afford it but Disney can if
they believe in it they'll throw money
at it you know and hopefully but
sometimes artists just don't want to
play you know in the audience we got a
Curtis van a delight says a teacher
question recommendation for top skills
students should work on with editing
yeah yeah you know so um one of the
first things uh uh I the first bits of
advice I heard uh when I entered the
trailer World from a producer named
Scott matui he said uh
uh your trailer editor needs two things
they need to know of Rhythm and they
need to know story uh you can learn
story a lot better than you can learn
rhythm
so they it's it's tough to really teach
Rhythm it's tough to throw seven shots
at somebody and say make it work
together you know uh but if you have a
semblance of that everything else you
can pick up and learn you know
um so that's really what they look for I
always say to anybody who's like trying
to get in to the business it like cut as
many fan things as you can cut for
shitty movies cut for movies that you
like that you you thought you didn't
have a good campaign and do something
completely different and don't really
worry about telling the story because
people are generally looking for the
Rhythm and the feel and that mood of how
you can cut three different images
together you know like a great piece of
advice right there from Andrew Hagley
kids cutter of the wakanda forever
trailer cutter extraordinaire works over
at Disney
um when you do you have uh what's your
source for music do you uh uh we've got
a bunch of CDs that you burn and Pull
Apart uh yeah I work with um some really
amazing music supervisors uh Evelyn
Garcia is my current supervisor I worked
with uh this guy Omar Herrera before uh
Brian
um
I I just work with a bunch of really
great people and they know music way
better than I do and they generally I I
have my own playlist on Spotify
sometimes that [ __ ] will get through and
when it does I feel like a million bucks
because I feel like I'm doing like you
know the big thing which is fine in the
queue but most of the time they're
pulling up playlists and and doing all
that stuff and that is that is the big
thing it's finding the queue isn't it
like at the end of the day you've got
two minutes to get into their head and
heart there's no better way to do that
than with music even with visuals on
your side it's like you need that
[ __ ] song to build around yeah man
yeah
so what's up next for you what's the
next trailer you're working on if you
can tell us oh I can't tell you
unfortunately but I I'm like no joke I'm
working on something now that like is
the reason I joined this company and
like they the day I interviewed for this
job they announced that this movie was
gonna happen like five years ago and uh
I was like this is the same difference I
gotta I gotta I gotta work on it and uh
been working on it and it's been like
the greatest privilege of my life it's
great and yeah yeah can't say anything I
I don't want you to get in trouble the
um that Fango shirt man it's [ __ ]
top-notch
Alabama I worked at Franco when I was a
wee young lab no way really I did my
first job out of college I was a I was
an assistant editor for starlog and then
along with that came the assistant
manager for fangorion Comic scene so
yeah I I I believe that blood as well
right on man it helped I'll tell you
another thing the best thing if you want
to be a trailer editor and you go and
and you try to get your phone the door
being a nerd and a geek about this [ __ ]
is like it's the best it will help so
much because you need that passion you
know uh yeah absolutely true we um I
spent the weekend blowing up the Lions
gave folks who did our marketing camp in
and cut like what I feel is a Exquisite
[ __ ] trailer uh for clerks three
where I'm like I know the movie and I
wouldn't even know where to begin
trying to put it together and they put
together a trailer that like first pass
I saw is basically the exact same pass
that everyone else is seeing one shot
was swapped out for something else like
you know and that was we got a song by
lit in the movie My Own Worst Enemy and
so they were like oh let's go with that
as the central song and in the movie
it's used prominently but not it's not
like an opening song or ending song and
the fact that they zeroed in on it I
thought was really interesting and
that's what pushed it through everyone
was just like I [ __ ] love that song
man like it's such an earworm
um it is I have nothing but respect for
that is a great trailer by the way it is
so great it did a nice job right like
yeah that's fun it brings you back you
know it really puts you in that time and
place and and everything that Randy's
probably gonna get and you're right it
really does come down to feeling all of
that [ __ ] is about what you feel in that
[ __ ] two minutes and the ultimately
the feeling they want you to have have
is like I gotta see that and [ __ ] but
it's it's a complex [ __ ] art form man
it started you know as a in the world of
the commercial but it truly is beyond
artistic at this point it's a gift that
you got thanks man I wanna I wanna can I
shout out one more thing
and when Mark when you ask the favorite
trailers
absolutely uh uh Little Children is a
masterpiece social networks and
Masterpiece uh Steve Harris cut uh my
friend Steve Harris cut this trailer for
Kill Bill the first one he he lied
granted he lied because it said in 2003
when thermal Kill Bill yeah that didn't
happen
but he did a little thing in that which
is the most inspiring it's the kitchen
sink thing of right when it says Uma
Thurman she opens the trunk and you hear
Quentin Tarantino just go action
breaking the fourth wall and it's just
like the most brilliant marketing
strategy I I I I always think like what
could be the action for anything and I
never got anywhere close to that
see look at that that is deep Cuts geeky
man you could tell that's why you're
good at your job you give a [ __ ] about
this [ __ ] man he loves it and and it's
like it's not like you're like yeah but
what I really want to do is you're like
I'm here this is what I want to do man
good for you all right once again
I don't know what Disney's paying you
but I vote you get paid more
thank you I'm gonna do I'm again I'm
gonna screen cap that my boss say listen
to Kevin Smith all right I uh they're
like we never do We're Not Gonna begin
it now I uh as I tell many people the
that I get to meet in life uh who do
things that I absolutely adore I heart
your art my friend excellent job I
really appreciate that brother it's a
dog's name Indy
named after
my favorite movie character yeah good
boy I think we just put together a
mystery kids
no you didn't
um
faster faster yeah you didn't you didn't
see anything Andrew it was so nice that
we were uh responded and jumped on uh
but more importantly thank you for for
what you do doing the Lord's work kid
thank you so much I I uh really
appreciate it guys and uh all the love
all the love of it goes to Ryan coogler
in that group it like holy [ __ ] they are
just the best absolutely that's amazing
everyone give it up for Andrew Hagley
man what a good day Andrew
um [ __ ]
I could do that God damn the whole show
man that's like
that's just interesting [ __ ]
I know like people like to see like
[ __ ] famous people talk but like
that's a rock star right there man
literally like how often do you get to
hear from the person who did something
how many times you watched that trailer
you said like seven
think of another artist who [ __ ] you
watch seven [ __ ] times bro
yeah in a day in a day that's what I'm
saying like there's that's an artist
right there and you we both appreciated
the [ __ ] I Was art as does the whole
planet the [ __ ] thing is got zillions
of views and [ __ ] and then chat people
were talking about that [ __ ] trailer
is fantastic
um he's very sweet of course he's
absolutely right all credit goes back to
Ryan and Co for the material and stuff
but
um man I'm telling you that's a it's a
gift to be able to do that [ __ ]
oh yeah it's it's what we used to call a
tone poem it's like we're not we're not
we're not giving you a narrative we're
just making you feel something we're
giving you things that that Inspire
emotions and not plot it's really yeah
it was and it's nice to hear too that
he's one of the YouTube kids man he was
just like I got [ __ ] just because I like
cutting [ __ ] that entire [ __ ] first
wave of YouTube kids like who are just
like oh this is fun like they're all
[ __ ] rich and have good jobs now
they're all happy they're all happy yeah
I want to track down his Looper trailer
I want to see the uh the the short film
that made it that broke Andrew higler
big
[ __ ] crazy man
um how wonderful
um all right so we did all the marble
stuff a sandman trailer played kid and
it's out there you can see it we
obviously can't show trailers here
because they [ __ ] throw us offline
for some reason yeah but my God the
trailer was beautiful I can't wait to
watch that that's happening dropping
three days after my birthday so all
right next every Friday yeah I'm gonna
be sitting the [ __ ] and that's Netflix
puts it all up at once none of this Hulu
[ __ ] right
uh Netflix drops everything at once
they're not [ __ ] with it I cannot
wait man I've Loved sand Manson's
[ __ ] first issue debuted can't wait
the trailer looks absolutely [ __ ]
phenomenal beautiful Sumptuous yeah I
also saw they dropped a couple of scenes
yeah I'm saying man they dropped uh it's
a lovely scene
with uh with death coming to claim
somebody's life and it's it's it's you
know Morpheus and and and uh and death
showing up to this old violinist this
old guy who's just playing his violin
and
and he stops playing and he's like do
you know who I am I mean yeah
I'm not ready yet
it's like oh well you know you get as
much time as anybody gets you get a
lifetime
you know he says a quick prayer in in
Hebrew and then he stands up and get
ready to go and it's it's this gorgeous
tiny little scene but it's beautiful and
then they have another scene where it's
Morpheus returning to hell to get his
helmet back from the demon who stole it
and so you get some Gwendolyn Christie
as Lucifer Morningstar
um and it's great so I can't I can't
[ __ ] wait next Friday oh my God it
looks [ __ ] gorgeous Friday it begins
kids the uh
you get what everyone gets you get a
lifetime that was the scene at that
moment scene now it's a scene in a show
but until recently it was just a moment
in a comic book that I was thinking
about when I was laying on the [ __ ]
table during the massive heart attack
one of the things that made me okay with
the notion of like oh [ __ ] I may die in
here tonight there's an eight percent
chance I'm gonna die in this room was
that moment where he's just like you
know what do I get she's like you got
what everybody gets you got a life
and I was like so did I all right man I
get it Gaiman helped me [ __ ] try to I
I was exiting this world I was ready to
go because I thought of some beautiful
[ __ ] Neil Gaiman wrote and then that son
of a [ __ ] and Dr Mark saved my life
thank you
but I'm glad he did because all them
[ __ ] phase five movies I'm here oh my
God
um
like uh what else I guess that's it
that's it I mean the last the last bit
of business for the show is uh is the
passing of two greats one had way more
to do in genre than the other but
um Paul Sorvino oh my God yes I'd
[ __ ] just saw this man [ __ ] yeah
passed away and and yeah sorvino's Dad
mayor sorvino's dad
um and there there are a couple of
things that of course everybody loves
him for I mean he was always a very
genial mobster
um that seemed to be the the role that
he that he seemed to play in Hollywood I
just re-watched the firm last night
which he shows up at the end of and he's
absolutely wonderful as well yeah I mean
I I I I think I first I first came to
him in in Goodfellas of course but then
I I I was surprised to encounter him in
lots of different places
um and the two that always struck me was
William Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet
Bes lerman's version of Romeo and Juliet
where he plays Juliet's dad
um I think or is it Romeo is dead I
think it's Juliet
um and he's just big and up Braddock and
he's just bellowing Opera from his from
his you know from the top of his lungs
and then he played wharf's adopted
brother on an episode of Star Trek the
Next Generation yeah I was like is that
[ __ ] Paul sorvine yet yeah it is
doing sci-fi and playing a
Russian son of a I mean brother of a
Klingon
um
and then you know so just beloved by
Hollywood you know never never got the
hosanna's he probably should have gotten
um given his body of work
um but uh but but had a definite role to
play and it was happy to hear from it
and just stretches stretches gifts a
little bit
um and then the other person to pass
away was a huge bucket of win as we say
on [ __ ] Hollywood Babylon
um thank God we had Paul Sorvino
um you know he I'm a I was he still
remained a huge Law and Order kid not
all of them but Law and Order the
[ __ ] Flagship show
like it means a lot to me it played a
big we watched it when we had the kid
and so it's always wrapped up with that
the kid you know the show used to begin
and boom boom boom didn't matter what
the kid was doing she was like six
months eight months no I guess a year
she was doing this [ __ ] she could sit up
she couldn't quite walk
um she'd be crawling and then all of a
sudden boom boom boom boom boom and the
kid would
be nice so he was a big he had a whole
season where he was a character and [ __ ]
and his [ __ ] his cop character like I
think he got shot or and then he got shy
about the job and and left and stuff uh
what a wonderful actor a huge [ __ ]
loss man but thank God we had him at all
he gave us some great [ __ ]
indeed
um and then the other actor who passed
um had a lot more to do in genre but
also just did a lot more in general
um more than almost anybody else except
for like James Hong
um David Warner
um God [ __ ]
yeah you know if if you haven't
encountered David Warner you have you
just didn't know that it was David
Warner but he he was very good at
playing bad guys and so did so quite a
bit in in movies like time after time
that's the first time I saw him too he
played Jack the Ripper he played Jack
the Ripper uh Time Bandits where he
played on he played the ultimate Evil In
Time band the ultimate Evil and then the
master control program and Sark and Tron
he was a heavy in Titanic he was I mean
God he was in Sam pickinpaw's The Ballad
of cable Hoge Raysha ghoul in Batman the
Animated Series indeed he's he's been in
three separate iterations of Star Trek
he was in the final frontier his
Chancellor gorkhan he was in a
Kardashian officer in Star Trek the Next
Generation I mean he Jesus he's been
he's been in everything he was in
[ __ ] the band with Two Brains he was
in Timber
in The Omen he got his name
oh yeah I mean he's made some 228
different acting credits and uh the
quote he gives is when others say no he
once said I say yes
sometimes he got the part because he was
the cheapest one available uh
um I was very sad to see this news
um not the least of which because I've
been a lifelong fan quite like you
um but uh we were trying to get him for
Masters yeah to do a voice and uh we
would we just we kind of kind of
conversation about like what about oh my
God David Warner so
um yeah it's when I read the news this
morning I was like we just missed him
man
um what a legend an absolute Legend and
what a fixture of my childhood I
remember going to see Time Bandits with
my father
um and talking about it the whole
ride home because I was a Catholic
school kid and I was like well
they're their version of
God and the devil
was you know I don't know it's not even
close to ours and my father looked at me
like I was an idiot like
[ __ ] movies got Sean Connery in it
what are you
I got an idiot as a [ __ ] child yeah
um yeah man David Warner huge part of
pop culture huge part of uh everything
I've watched and enjoyed over the years
uh
he will be missed big bucket away what a
goddamn I feel like you're cold
he was 82 years old no 80 80. I was
actually looking forward to like being
able to tell him like oh my god dude
time after time oh my god dude Time
Bandits oh my God like
I mean if you were a kid like us who
came of age in the in the 80s and the
90s and you were like us watching movies
on video because you went to the video
store to rent [ __ ]
he was in French Lieutenant's Woman he
was in the company of wolves he was in
wax work
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 2 secret of
the use
John carpet is in the mouth of Madness
Scream 2 and Mary Poppins returns in
2018. oh my God he was in the recent
Mary Poppins movie he was he was in Twin
Peaks he was on Larry Sanders show like
this is just a dude who [ __ ] worked
yeah man he put himself out there good
for him because now he'll be with us
forever
John but certainly not forgotten uh the
word persists
uh thank you legend for the time you
gave us and the work you did you
captured our imaginations
indeed
um well there it is that's all the news
we got for you sadness but uh but you
know we had a lot of good news prior to
that
we did we talked a lot about Marvel
excellent [ __ ] guests and Andrew
Hagley
um [ __ ] got to hear about one of my
favorite subjects in the world [ __ ]
trailers
and how they're made and [ __ ]
uh kids
thanks for hanging out you all have a
good time everybody enjoy themselves
everybody learn a thing or two
we're glad you're here can't do it
without you uh thanks so much don't
forget I made a motion picture we should
we had a panel in Hall age and it was
wonderful a lot of very emotional
considering like [ __ ] clerks is a
funny movie very emotional across the
boards uh you can watch the whole ass
panel after we're done here on my
YouTube channel it's 90 minutes it's
really good Chase is very funny in it
um and uh clerks Three is coming to a
theater near you September 13th
September 15th on fathom event screens
or watch a myth with me when I'm on the
road when I take the movie out for the
convenience tour
uh tickets at clerks three dot movie
right now uh if you're in North Carolina
I'm going to Galaxy con this weekend
tickets at cspod.com and if you're in
New Jersey on August 2nd why I'm
celebrating my birthday and Jason Muse's
birthday I'm 50 turning 52 Eastern East
48 uh so the event is called 100 Years
of Jay and Silent Bob take pictures of
this then watch our good old show at
night and
see the first five minutes of Clerks
three on a big screen in a movie theater
oh it's going to be good times kids
as always at csmod.com sir do you have
anything you would like to plug
um not especially
um but if you if you'd like to get a
copy of a door in the distance it's
currently on sale at uh at whatever uh
comic book store you would like to go
buy it from or Amazon or whatever but go
to a comic shop go in there pick it up
pick some other stuff up and kids here's
a little inside baseball uh me and uh
Mark been talking about uh Mark coming
out to the east coast and doing a
signing at Jay and Silent Bob so you can
stash and if we're gonna do that
naturally we would do Hollywood Babylon
while we're out there as well uh back in
the past it would have been like well
50-seat Hollywood Babylon a whole bunch
instead Batman Beyond now and Beyond
what did I say not Babylon
oh my God thank you man I was like shut
up I'm on a roll he's like I need to
break uh fat man beyond sorry
um so we will uh when Mark comes out and
we're trying to figure out what that day
will be because I start touring with
clerk three September 4th
um we'll be able to do it in like a 300
seater and [ __ ] like that it'd be a big
show it'll be it'll be great so you'll
be able to get your Dora signed and
you'll be able to see fat man beyond
live
oh what Mighty times there will be
Babylon is on my mind because uh we have
a Babylon show August 5th tickets at
ceasemod.com at Flappers here in West
Hollywood
um but there it is kids what a good time
[ __ ] man I can sit around talking about
horrible trailers forever
and then talking to a guy who cuts
Marvel trailers it's even better [ __ ]
dreaming [ __ ] dreaming
uh don't forget kids the Roosevelt's
Megan Kevin Smith collaboration look at
that [ __ ] look at that look at those
designs look at it
[Laughter]
look at my tits yes
um thank you for hanging out my friends
um thank you for taking the time
what a [ __ ] fun night it's been
indeed uh there it is kids if you like
this show at all [ __ ] thank the other
guy give it up for marvelous Mark
Bernard and everybody
thank you sir always a pleasure
and if you're feeling horny give it up
for me
ladies and gentlemen that
is fat man beyond for this evening I am
Kevin Smith and I am Mark Bernard tune
in same fat Time same fat channels
podcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
everybody
[Music]
wakanda forever oh that too
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]